have you ever looked at your own
celebrity net worth I have but I don't
remember it it says you've got 13
million if I'm worth 13 million it's
when I'm dead I'm from Food Stamps and
powdered milk that motherfcker might say
I make 13 million I might actually be
worth that if we sold all our [__] but
our finances are so tied up in the [__]
company I don't live like that my house
ain't no million dollar house should we
pull up Steve's and that worth I think
it says I'm worth 2.5 W they bumped me
up to four there's no way I got more
money than you son what are we talking
about here what the [__]
I what I got 13 million and steo got
four what's bam at these days he said 5
million wow dude how many million does d
have
3.5 that's probably accurate he does own
a lot of Real Estate